There's new information tonight.
And what by even George based
George Santos
standards, was one of the more bizarre
and frankly disturbing allegations
against him involving
not only deception
but possible
financial fraud as well,
involved his association
with a veteran in New Jersey
whose dog was dying
and desperately needed surgery.
The veteran has told CNN that Santos
helped raise money
to aid the dog using a Go Fund Me page
veteran who at the time
was homeless living in a tent
says he never saw the roughly $3,000
that was raised and that later
his dog died.
Seen as Omar
Jimenez joins us
now with more on this story.
So what more have you learned?
Well, Richard
Sarvis, the Navy veteran,
he told us today that two FBI agents
came to his home today
to to ask him about obviously
this entire ordeal,
as you just said,
where he has said that Santos helped him
raise money
for life saving surgery,
for his dying dog.
Never got that money.
The dog died
four months later
and also said he was cooperative.
He turned over text messages
that he had exchange
with Santos back in 2016,
which is right around
when this entire ordeal happened.
A very tough time in his life
as he detailed
and when he spoke
about all of this Ossoff
to CNN just a few weeks ago.
This is a little of what he said
Do you have a heart
Do you have a soul
He probably would lie
about that.
I mean, I don't want you to ever hurt
anybody like you hurt me again, George.
And nobody else
should ever have to go through that.
I almost killed myself
when that dog died.
That's why I'm here.
I don't want him
to be able to do this again.
And on the latest developments,
a spokesperson for the U.S.
attorney's office
for the Eastern District of New York
did not have a comment here.
Neither did
George Santos
when he was asked about it
on Capitol Hill today.
Now, when this story was coming out
just last month,
Santos said that he had no idea
about all of this,
but obviously those are claims
that he's making up against those of us.
And reportedly,
it seems like he has some text messages.
Is there any sense of a timeline of
if the FBI was talking to
the veteran today?
A timeline of their investigation?
Well, he's
got a lot of investigations going on.
At this point
into his personal finances,
into his campaign finances.
At least one
congressman
from New York does
believe that this investigation
could move much quicker
than those on the campaign finance side.
To use his words, he said that U.S.
attorneys
are the only ones that can move
at the pace necessary
to actually get some answers
on a normal timetable here.
But obviously, a lot of questions,
not a whole lot of answers.
Appreciate it.
Thanks very much.
I'm joined
now by CNN's Andrew
Kosinski, who has a new report
on CNN Economy.
It's pretty fascinating details,
pieces together, new information
about Jorge Santos
when most people knew him as Anthony
Davis older.
So can you talk
What have you discovered
about kind of the evolution
of Anthony devolved into Jorge Santos?
Yeah, what we found
is pretty interesting.
Before 2019,
he didn't
post really about politics at all.
He posted about, you know, celebrities.
He went on a Real Housewives
talk show and took a selfie,
a big Lady Gaga fan.
But around you know 2019 January
this starts to change.
He sends lots of angry tweets
at politicians
people in New York specifically like AOC,
Chuck Schumer.
But he wasn't
really getting any attention.
No one was responding to him.
And he gets,
you know, sort of this pickup
when he joins
this group of sort of diverse
pro-Trump activists in New York City.
The Republican Party
was attempting to diversify.
And, you know,
here comes that,
you know, called
Anthony of older still at this time.
He's young, he's gay, he's Latino.
And he's allegedly,
according to him, very successful.
So how did that's
how he began
to make inroads with Republicans.
So the first instance that we found
where he really started
connecting people was in March of 2019.
There was this rally in New York City
at Trump Tower.
It was with Republicans
basically in the tri state area.
He shows up there
with the Gays for Trump sign.
There's video online of him yelling.
And another guy
who kind of basically came
to Rabble-rouser
with the Confederate flag
telling him to go home.
The next couple of days,
he attends these events
for this movement,
which is called the Walk Away Movement.
And it's basically
this movement to take people who are,
you know,
traditionally members
of the Democratic coalition,
you know, women, people of color
and tell them to leave
the Democratic Party
and come to the Republican Party.
He you know, he attends these events.
He says, I'm Anthony too vulgar.
I'm you know, I'm very successful.
I'm gay, I'm Latino.
And most importantly
to these people, he's a Trump supporter.
And at what point does
he decide to run to Congress?
So we found basically,
you know, with these events, he's
he's making connections.
You know, he's he's
he's meeting people at these events.
He's making connections.
They see him.
They see his story,
which is what
they find personally compelling.
And died in nine 11
and the Holocaust survivor
11 years he said working on Wall Street
and he you know
he starts this Facebook group
as you know
at the same time
to we're called united for Trump 2020
Like you know we talked
about just earlier that go fund me
go fund me.
He made these grandiose promises
and then around 2019
and the end of the year
he starts going to Queens event
he's running for office
under a new name he has
he actually is a
he goes to Queens
Queens Republican
okay you know he's he's meeting people
he even actually had
a public access talk show in Queens
and he's doing it now under this name
George Santos,
which even confused people who knew him.
We actually we have audio of him
introducing himself.
And there's a speaker
and he says, you know, who is this guy?
You know,
I thought his name was something else
is I think you have a give
a clip of that.
Yeah, we have we have audio of that.
We've got. Okay,
let's take a look,
folks.
Another important speaker,
the other congressional nominee
Jorge Santos,
Jorge, who we know is a friend
as he's known
as Anthony's of Older than me,
so I don't know where Jorge Santos
came into the thing,
but that's what it says. You know,
I'm a victim of circumstances.
My parents were Latino,
so it's George
Anthony, the holder Santos.
Is it George Anthony to voters?
That is that is actually his name.
I actually I posted a tweet once
where I had countered
ten different names.
He used George Santos,
Anthony Santos, George of older
Anthony's Brodsky.
No one really knows where
that one came from.
We know we reached out to his office.
We reached out to his attorney.
We asked, you know,
can we talk to you about his evolution,
how he got here?
Mike, you know, most people,
we didn't hear back.
That's not happened,
at least
while Andrew
Kaczynski things more fascinating is
up on CNN RT.com.